¿Cuáles de los siguientes triángulos son
similares al triángulo ABC?
El triángulo ABC es éste que nos indican
aquí y nos dan estas opciones.
Bueno, aquí como pueden ver yo ya vi cual
es la respuesta correcta,
pero lo que vamos a hacer es analizar
cada una de estas opciones
para verificar el porqué ésta es la respuesta correcta.
Ahora, vamos a recordar un poco qué son los
triángulos similares.
Recordemos que dos triángulos van a ser similares,
siempre y cuando todos sus
ángulos internos sean iguales.
Vamos a dibujar por ejemplo, este triángulo así...
y ahora voy a dibujar otro con diferentes dimensiones... más o menos... así.
Entonces un triángulo va a ser similar a
otro cuando tenemos que sus ángulos internos
correspondientes son congruentes o son iguales.
Este ángulo de aquí es igual a éste de
aquí, este ángulo de acá va a ser igual
al ángulo que está aquí y este ángulo
de aquí arriba, va a ser igual al ángulo
que se encuentra aquí, al correspondiente
en el orden en el que aparecen.
Lo genial de estos triángulos cuando demostramos
que son similares, es que podemos, una vez
que mostramos que lo son, podemos decir que
la proporción entre sus lados va a ser la misma,
por ejemplo, la proporción en este
lado de aquí que le voy a poner "a",
con respecto a este lado de acá,
que le voy a llamar "b",
esta proporción de "a" entre "b"... "a"... entre... "b"...
va a ser la misma proporción que si yo
tomo este lado correspondiente que le voy a llamar "c"
y este otro lado  de aquí abajo correspondiente a éste otro, que lo voy a llamar "d".
Así que esta proporción va a ser igual a
la del lado "c" con respecto al lado "d".
Bueno, ¿qué tiene que ver esto con el que
tengamos aquí una recta?
Bueno, la pendiente de esta recta va a ser
constante, el cambio en "x" va a ser perfectamente
horizontal y el cambio en "y" va a ser perfectamente
vertical,
de manera que se forma un triángulo rectángulo aquí.
Cualquier triángulo rectángulo que se construya
usando dos puntos que estén sobre esta recta,
serán similares entre sí.
Pues la proporción del cambio en "y" con
respecto al cambio en "x" será la misma.
Bueno, ahora vamos a resolver lo que nos piden acá.
Nos dicen, si este triángulo ABC que está aquí marcado,
vamos a compararlo con el que se forma por BEF...
vamos a ponerlo de un color diferente...
el triángulo formado por B...
por E...
BE...
y por F...
este triángulo formado, aquí...
Bueno, vemos que aquí esta inclinación de
la hipotenusa es diferente,
no es paralela a la de nuestra recta aquí.
Y aunque este forma un ángulo recto, pues podemos
ver de entrada que las proporciones no son correctas,
estos triángulos no son similares,
así que esta primera opción, no lo es.
Ya sé, ya sabemos que es la última, pero
de todas maneras vamos a analizar cada uno de ellos.
Ahora el triángulo formado por BDG...
usemos otro color...
el triángulo formado por B...
D... y G...
este triángulo de acá...
Bueno, éste también es todavía más obvio
que no es similar,
ya que esta inclinación de la hipotenusa es muy diferente a la de nuestra línea recta
que es la que forma la hipotenusa del triángulo que estamos comparando,
entonces bueno, esta opción
definitivamente tampoco lo es.
Ahora nos preguntan el triángulo formado
por E, F y G...
E, F y G... este triángulo de acá.
Está bastante más chiquito, pero igual,
estamos viendo que no es similar
al triángulo que tenemos acá.
Esta forma es muy diferente a la que tiene
la forma de este triángulo,
entonces esta opción tampoco es, la tachamos.
Y bueno, la que ya sabemos que sí es... pero
vamos a ver porque sí es
esta opción la buena...
A...
G... y D...
Ah bueno, aquí de entrada tanto D como A son dos puntos que están sobre esta misma recta y quedamos...
bueno, aquí vemos que forman ángulos rectos...
este segmento DG es completamente horizontal
y el segmento AG es completamente vertical,
forman un ángulo recto, es un triángulo rectángulo.
Y ya habíamos quedado que todos los triángulos
rectángulos que sean formados por dos puntos
sobre esta recta van a ser similares entre sí,
así es que este ADG que puse en
rojo es similar al original,
que de hecho aquí se alcanza a ver
comparte estos dos lados,
nada más tiene este otro segmento
que es paralelo al de aquí abajo.
Entonces todo esto confirma que efectivamente,
éste es triángulo similar al que nos dan aquí.